- Hello, good evening everyone.
I'm Lynn Cooley,
the Dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
I am pleased to welcome you
to our second presentation
in a series of conversations
with Yale graduate school alumni
sponsored by the Graduate School
and its wonderful alumni board.
This series called Perspectives,
is meant to bridge our alumni
and student communities,
sharing alumni experiences
and insights as both models for success,
and for opening opportunities for alumni
and students to connect.
I have ambitious goals for transforming
and evolving Yale's approach
to doctoral education,
as well as plans to strengthen
and build our alumni community,
to connect our faculty, administrators,
and students more frequently,
and to help ignite those connections
in support of our students.
I look forward to using what
we learned from this series
to think about how we can improve,
continue to improve
graduate student experiences
for all students at Yale.
Today, tonight, we will be joined
by Lyndsey McMillon-Brown, PhD,
alumni from the Department of Chemical
and Environmental Engineering.
Tarek Fadel, PhD, Assistant Director
of the Marble Center for
Cancer Nanomedicine at MIT
and our own Danica Tisdale-Fisher,
Assistant Dean for Diversity
here at the Graduate School.
We hope that you will
enjoy this conversation
about Lyndsey's scholarship
and the lessons she has
learned from her days
as a graduate student at Yale and beyond.
I'm delighted to have so
many graduate students
and alumni and a few
faculty I see on the list,
tuning in from around the world,
and I hope you will
enjoy the conversation.
- Thank you Lynn
and good evening everyone.
My name is Danica Tisdale-Fisher,
and I am Assistant Dean of Diversity
here at the Yale Graduate School.
Before we get started,
I'd like to share a few
housekeeping items with you.
We will be recording this webinar
and we'll share the recording
after the conversation.
We are offering close
captioning technology,
which you can access by
clicking the live broadcast link
in the top left-hand
corner of your screen.
In the second half of the session,
we will be saving time
for questions and answers.
Many graduate students and alumni
have submitted questions in advance.
And we also hope you will
enter additional questions
in the Q&A box during this webinar.
Now, I am delighted to introduce
Lyndsey McMillon-Brown.
Dr. McMillon-Brown is a
research electrical engineer
at NASA Glenn Research Center,
where she focuses on solar
cell materials development.
She is currently the
principal investigator
of $2.5 million early career initiative,
developing a new class of solar cells
that can be manufactured
in space and on the moon.
Prior to joining NASA,
Lyndsey earned her PhD
in chemical engineering
at Yale University in 2019,
where she researched novel materials
and nano patterns
for advanced light
trapping in solar cells.
Outside of the lab, Lyndsey is dedicated
to increasing opportunities
for underrepresented
individuals in STEM fields.
She challenges institutions
to commit to cultural changes
that provide more supportive environments
for their students.
We will be talking about
her experience today
and her recommendations
for how research spaces
can be more inclusive.
Dr. Terek Fadel will
start our conversation
about transitioning from graduate school
to a career in the sciences.
- Thanks so much Danica.
Can you guys hear me okay?
It is a pleasure to be here,
like Lyndsey, I'm a fellow,
I went to The Yale School of Engineering
and Applied Science.
And shortly after a postdoc at Yale,
I spent, well, it's been what,
10 years now, which is crazy.
I spent several years in science
policy focusing in a field
of nanoscience and emerging
technologies in Washington DC.
And now I manage a research center at MIT
called the Mobile Center
for Cancer Nanomedicine.
I'm so excited to
pertain this conversation
and Lyndsey, what an
amazing professional journey
you've had so far.
I really wanted to
start from the beginning
and ask you a little bit more
about how you first fell
in love with science
and how did you ultimately end up in NASA?
- Well, good evening everyone.
And I'm so happy to be
here with all of you today,
and Tarek, that's a great starting point.
I fell in love with science
from a really early age.
I was fortunate that both of my parents
were really enthusiastic about science.
So I got a lot of hands-on experience
with my dad outside
tinkering with the cars,
doing nature walks and hikes
and gathering, catching
animals that we could.
And my mom was really, had
the textbooks in order.
So we were learning things in the house
and getting those math skills together
and all those things.
So that really was a great
introduction to science.
I went to Space Camp as a
kid, and that was amazing.
It's a fun experience.
I would recommend it 10 out of 10.
So I had a really great time,
doing different science camps
and having that type of exposure,
which is a privilege that
not everyone gets access to,
but those experiences really did help me
fall in love with science.
And then I ended up at NASA
through more experiences,
doing internships.
So early in college,
I applied for a summer
internship opportunity
and that just so happened to
be in the field of solar cells.
I was always an environmentalist
and I thought that I knew solar cells
were kind of important
but I had no idea how they worked
and the science behind them.
So it was at that first internship
that I was exposed to
the research behind them
and the science and the engineering,
and I loved the technology,
and I loved how I felt.
I felt like I was making
a difference in the world
and really making a positive contribution.
So I was hooked at that point
and I continued through NASA as an intern,
and then I joined their co-op program,
and I'm happy to say,
I'm a civil servant there today.
- It's amazing, a lot of times
I have many conversations,
with graduate students post-doc,
a couple of them actually
in the participant list here tonight.
And it's remarkable
because he asked me a lot of times,
when you think about this journey,
is it a linear journey
or are there like many
pivots along the way?
I see you've done a lot of internships,
you've been able to kind
of just fall in love
with the stars, right?
And think a little bit more
about how to get there.
And you've had internships through it.
You went through Space Camp earlier on,
but did you ever feel like,
well, maybe I could use solar powers
and commercial applications.
Maybe I could shift there,
was it more of like a
process of elimination
or was it kind of like, I
know what I'm going to do
and I'm gonna head there,
I'm gonna just be bold and go for it.
- Yeah, I think I was fortunate enough
to be able to realize the goal
and decide I would love to do solar panels
and I'd love to do them at NASA.
And fortunately those
doors swung open for me.
So I was able to stay on that path.
And I did a lot of
exploration along the way,
but I still kind of had
that end goal in mind.
So I did some research on
medical devices along the way.
I was able to work at Johnson and Johnson
and engineer a bit of medical devices.
So I had some diverse experiences
and I've definitely flirted
with the idea of some other things.
There's so much, so many fun things to do.
I was a mechanical engineering
major and undergrad,
and I was very entranced by cars.
So I thought I would be in
the automotive industry maybe,
designing the next generation of cars.
And then you see that
as an actual engineer,
you're like working on a screw
that goes in the left
door panel of the car.
So that became a little less attractive
but I was really interested
in a lot of different things,
but solar was really been the home for me.
- And it's amazing to hear that.
You mentioned your parents,
a lot of these discussions
about how the tales of pivots
or jumps from one adventure to another
in the world of science,
it can be driven a lot
of times by your passion
for what you do, what you
tinker with or what you work on,
but a lot of times it is the engagement
and we'll get to that later as well,
but with the people, right?
And you mentioned at how your parents
kind of inspired you
to go through all of the Space Camp,
had the books stacked up and ready to go.
But do you feel that that
played a big role as well
in terms of where you
ended up at the end or...
- Absolutely, it was a huge role.
And I think the biggest thing
that my parents enabled for me
that I didn't even realize necessarily
or appreciate until I got much older,
was that they instilled the skills
and the belief that I
belonged in any space
that I was interested in.
So it was fine
and they encouraged the fact
that I like to get outside
and get dirty, there weren't
things for boys versus girls
and there weren't spaces
that maybe you don't want to do this.
They encouraged it and nurtured it
and gave me those experiences
that they saw excited me.
So that really allowed
me to view the world
as endless possibilities,
and I didn't have any
limitations on myself.
- That's great, I want to talk more
about these endless possibilities.
I want to shift a little bit more
to think a little bit more.
Let's continue that in
that realm of pivots
and as you know more than anyone here,
often in space, we go from very, very hot,
to very, very, very cold.
And I could probably say the same
about graduate school sometimes
when it comes to what
you're doing in the lab
and experiencing successes and failure.
I remember back in the days,
if my cell culture got contaminated,
oh my goodness, it was
the end of the world.
And then when the experiment worked,
it's kind of like, right?
It's just the best feeling in the world.
And so, Yale is such an amazing place
and it is so unique,
and there's such a breadth of resources
and the people there.
And I just wanna hear a little bit more
about how you manage these ups and downs
while you were there.
- Yeah, so I took kind of
a multifaceted approach
to managing those ups and downs.
And one of the key things
was having a support system
and a support network.
So I had the support network of my family
that was ready-made and always
there with me and for me,
but then I also had
this new support network
that I was building at Yale,
and that consisted of the friends
that I made organically on campus,
and they were interdisciplinary
studying different things.
And we supported each other
through the hot and cold,
the ups and downs,
and trials and tribulations of
the graduate school journey.
And then in many instances,
there would not necessarily
be the exact support
that I wanted around.
And in those instances,
I would get together
with friends on campus
and we would build it ourselves.
And I think that's important to do
because a lot of times we are in spaces
that are not yet ready for
people like us to be in.
So women in STEM
or people of color in these
tremendously new environments
that have been historically
under representing people.
So it's important that we make space
and claim space that we need
to support us through these times.
And for me, that looked
like co-founding the society
of women engineers,
with some women in the chemical
and environmental engineering program,
that was co-founding the Yale
League of Black Scientists
with two physicists, Charles
Brown and Brooke Russell.
And also I found a great home
at the university church at Yale.
And that was where I really felt community
and felt welcome.
And it wasn't the STEM support
and it wasn't in my field or discipline,
but it really fed my soul.
And we sometimes forget
that we are whole people
and I needed to nourish my whole self.
So I was able to kind of
build that support network
across campus in many different places.
- I love that.
And nourishing your
whole self is definitely,
just a recurring kind of quality that feel
that all of us kind of need
throughout this journey
in graduate school and beyond.
And it's just remarkable
how much of a moment when
certainty can be when,
you feel like you're dwelling yourself
into a subject of research,
whether it's in the sciences or beyond,
and a lot of the,
it seems like a lot of
kind of your existence,
kind of revolves around it.
And it's just, it's great.
and I wanted to kind of just remember
how enabling that landscape on campus was,
but also to not just forget about,
I mean, you started a SWEE chapter, right?
Can you tell somebody,
well, I mean, I love how you go,
but really, it was amazing
and it took a lot of efforts
and just being able to convince yourself
and then seeing around you,
and just being like, you know what?
We need this,
and can you tell us a bit more,
how did that happen?
- Yeah, so that was
definitely a proud moment
in grad school.
And that came from a group
of us women grad students,
sitting in Mason lab at lunch,
talking about, well, at
my undergrad, we had this
and my undergrad had this,
and that's what we need around here.
Gripe, gripe, grumble, grumble.
And finally we had kicked it around enough
and we were actually telling me undergrads
that were also in the
engineering departments,
telling them these tall tales
of what our SWEE chapters used to do
and how we felt community there,
and what a rich experience this was,
how you're able to host girl scout days
and reach out to local girl scout troops
to inspire the next generation.
And there were enough of us around
and excited about it.
And I think it was something
that we really wanted to
give to the undergrads
so that they could have the
same experience and support
and love for the organization that we did.
So we were led by Bridget Heggerty
and we were able to found this chapter,
get it recognized.
It began as the grad chapter,
but there's a thriving undergrad chapter
and it's still there.
And women are still benefiting
from that chapter at Yale.
And we go to the annual
conference each year,
which has been tremendously valuable
for the undergrads seeking employment.
They have a great job fair at
the SWEE Annual Conference.
So it's kind of the, it
nurtured us in the moment
when we founded it.
And it gave us something
to do that we believed in,
but it's still paying off so well
for the future generations.
And we're proud of that.
- That's amazing.
Yeah, it's phenomenal.
I feel like when you start these types
of new initiatives and efforts
and provide this new support structure,
you always wonder, how
is this sustainable?
And it feels amazing to just to know
that it still exists
and it's still going.
And that's awesome.
I wanted to shift gear
a little bit more now,
about being a NASA Glenn
and how you're leading
the study of solar cells.
So this is part of the
Artemis Program, right?
- Correct.
- So you providing
astronauts new superpowers
and what I mean by that solar power.
And so how did you make the transition
from being in graduate school?
So we talked about internships and all,
but it's remarkable
because when you transitioned
into this new workplace
and you have to adapt, right?
I mean, we're talking
about accountability,
resources are changing,
your workspace is changing,
the people you're engaged with,
what are the things you had to learn
on your own in this journey?
- Yeah, so I had to learn a lot,
but I did come in after
the experience of the PhD
with some comfort of the
research and the science
and understanding how to
tackle a large problem.
So those were some of the
tools that I had already had,
but one thing I've really had to learn,
is how do you nurture and
manage the people on your team?
And people are really important to me.
So I wanted to do this with tact.
When do you push
and when do you give
grace and accommodate?
And I don't know that that's
something that can be taught,
but it is something
that I think is critical
no matter what we do.
Then there are things about
running a research group
like how do you initiate collaborations
with researchers that
you want to work with,
but who you don't know personally yet,
who you don't have a relationship with?
And then the administrative tax,
man, they get me every day.
That's the one thing I'm
always griping about.
And those tasks have been
greater than I anticipated.
I envisioned the life as a PI
where I was really still in the lab,
but I have to fight for that time
because now I have to keep the
supplies for everybody else,
I have to make sure the
contracts are up to date.
So the postdocs are getting paid
and safety permits,
and meetings with program managers,
and you have to get the money
and then drum up support for more money
and publish the papers,
and traveling to give talks around
at different labs and universities.
So it's been a lot to handle,
but I've been fortunate to have mentors
and people around that
can give me that advice.
I think it's important to try to identify
what you don't know so that
you can get help with it.
So yeah, leveraging relationships
has been really important
in this transition time for me.
- Yeah, I'm hearing a
lot of great things here.
I mean, first of all, the
reality of a private investigator
and into sciences, right?
And how this new reality is
really wearing many hats,
learning how to manage your
budget, advocating, policy,
managing people, conflict,
not just what's happening on
the bench or projects, right?
And I feel like it's a new reality
that is not just, in your
setting for instance,
but also in academia.
And I want it to just kind of go back
and think about all the great
things you've done on campus.
When were at Yale, you actually,
you did the diligence effort
to actually get flavors of that,
through the Advanced Graduate
Leadership Fellow Program,
through some of the governance structures,
you've even stored through SWEE.
I feel like there's definitely
some sort of linkage, right?
But ultimately I think that
the one take home there
is that science is not that simple
to begin with on the
scientific end for sure
but also in the human aspect of it
and (indistinct) aspect of it.
And then like the menu has
that we have to wear nowadays.
Yeah, no, it's remarkable.
Do you have any comments though,
in terms of how your experience of depth
and breadth for Yale engineering
has helped you kind of
just provide this affinity
to do all these different
things you're doing now in NASA?
- Yes, it's helped tremendously.
So I realized I was in a really
good position technically
because I had experience writing papers.
And also as a grad student, I
had experience writing grants.
So that was great to come in with that,
like that experience
and that hardware to be able to do that.
And then as you mentioned,
you kind of build up
this toolbox of skills,
transferable skills
that as a grad student,
they were fun pastimes and activities,
but then you realize,
oh, I'm able to do this
because of these previous experiences.
So from being a resident coordinator
over the graduate housing,
I had experience running a large team
and having a fairly large budget
with goals and milestones,
and making sure those were met
to satisfy the needs of a community.
I had a lot of experience
working with diverse individuals.
I had also as a resident coordinator,
I learned a lot about different
marginalized identities
and what challenges
other people might face.
And by having to go to the
different resources on campus,
I learned a lot about people.
So I'm able to implement that
and how do we diversify STEM,
and how to, I make sure that all people
of all identities feel welcome, seen
and heard in any space
that I'm sharing with them.
So there were so many skills
that I was able to learn and transfer.
So I'm really grateful
for that experience.
And then there's just
the diversity of thought
that is the Yale experience
and that has enriched
my life tremendously.
So I had friends in grad school
that were in the humanities
and doing PhDs in different disciplines.
And just from having lunch with them
or catching up, you hear
what they're reading,
what they're writing about.
And that has enriched
me so much as a person.
If you probably were to
look at my bookshelf,
you would think I was
in like the humanities
and not a scientist
because I find their work so interesting.
So they kind of ignite this
whole other side of my brain
and I'm grateful to have
a better understanding
of the world that we live in.
And that was absolutely acquired from Yale
and from those diverse people
that I met with different studies.
- Thank you so much.
Yeah, we talked a little bit about that.
Actually my recollection,
my favorite moments really
were the first Friday of five,
where I would just go
and mingle with people
in international relations
and in humanities.
That was my favorite
part, people were like,
"Oh, this is great,
you're doing the biomedical engineering
or you're so close to the med school."
I'm like, "No, I'm actually
close to the theater."
That's where I want to go (laughs).
- Yes.
- So anyway, thank you
so much, this is great.
I want to yield back to Danica
who has also a lot of questions to ask.
Thank you so much.
- [Lyndsey] Thank you.
- Thank you Tarek
and Lyndsey, I've been so inspired
to hear you talk more about how you work
to create the community
that you believed you
could thrive in at Yale.
And so I wanted to ask you
sort of based on your many experiences
in STEM outreach and mentoring,
especially as a member of SWEE and YLBS
and other groups while you were at Yale.
What are your thoughts about how students
or recent graduates
from underrepresented
communities especially,
can navigate through today's STEM climate
both academically or professionally?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So I think, there are a
lot of solutions to that,
and I think it's really important
that you find a space
where you can be your authentic self,
be sure to bring your authentic self
and don't sacrifice.
I think a lot of people have,
there can be external pressure
to be a little bit less you,
whatever makes you, you.
So that you fit in with the status quo
of what people may incorrectly think,
is representative of the field
that you aspire to be in.
But I always argue for the opposite.
I think it's tremendously important
to be uniquely you
because I think that broadens the access
to your field for many
other people than just you.
So I think it's important,
I am a scientist,
I am a woman, I love
football, I like makeup.
And I think bringing all of those things
will help someone see, you
don't have to be a nerd.
You can watch, Sunday Night Football
and still do this whole science thing,
and you can paint your nails
and still put on the lab coat
and get in the lab.
So I think it's important
to be your authentic self,
find community and make community,
and be community for other people.
Community isn't always found
where you would like it to be
or where it should formally be.
So if you're not finding the support
that you would like in your department,
get outside, swing the doors open.
And if you're a scientist
explore other departments in the hill
and see if you can find people,
maybe your support system is
going to be in the med school
or in the law school
or with people around.
For me, the university
church was a great space
for me to find that support.
And then always I was relying on people
who had been through
what I'd been through.
I found mentors that were in positions
where I would like to be,
but I never want to overlook the wisdom
of people that are not in your field,
but still have kind of navigated
through the world that we're in today.
So I think you can learn a great deal
from so many people.
And find advocates, people
who advocate for you.
And an advocate is someone
who will speak your name into
rooms that you are not there.
And when opportunities come up,
when awards are being discussed,
positions that will help
elevate you to the next level.
And that can be difficult to find
but it's important to try
to find those advocates.
- Thank you for that.
I love this idea of sort of
busting the myth wide open
about what a scientist
or what a scholar should
look like and be like,
and bringing your most authentic self
to all of these spaces.
I think in the work that I do,
I see that that's a question
many students often have,
is how real can I be in these spaces?
And so I love that you're
offering the advice
to be your most authentic self.
Just to pivot just a bit though,
I do want to ask
about gender diversity in
science and engineering.
We often talk about a leaky pipeline
referring to sort of the
decreasing proportion of women
and underrepresented minorities in STEM.
I want to ask you what you
suggest graduate schools can do
to not only attract,
but also to retain new
generations of scientists.
- So I have been inspired
to push back on the concept
of the leaky pipeline,
because when we talk
about a leaky pipeline,
that's suggesting a passive loss,
but in reality,
the pipeline that we exist in has valves
and they're restricting
access to some people
based on their identities.
And those identities can
be race, sexuality, gender,
physical ability, myriad things.
So how do we fix this pipeline?
How do we stop this restriction of access?
So I think it's really important
to make underrepresented students
or team members feel seen all of the time
and create an environment
that is supportive
and collaborative for them.
Everyone should be encouraged to speak
and that they have an
equal voice in the team.
I think the graduate
school and all programs
should implement holistic
admissions processes
that focused more on research potential
by like qualitative assessments
and de-emphasize metrics
like the GRE and GPA
that are actually been proven
to be ineffective predictors
for research performance
and degree completion.
Research has shown that
letters of recommendation
are the strongest predictor for success
in graduate school programs.
So I also think we should make
academic faculty candidate
lists that are diverse.
We need to diversify the faculty
because that's going
to aid in the retention
and recruitment of diverse students.
We need to make sure that
we're taking serious looks
at these diverse candidates
and deans and department chairs
should be rejecting shortlist
that lacked diversity.
I would also encourage you that you hire
or recruit your diverse
candidates and clusters
so that these candidates have cohort.
They also need support and community,
so that they can give
so much of themselves
to the department, the
school, their scholarship,
and the students that will
inevitably flop to them
for support and mentorship.
So really the bottom line here is that,
you need to ensure
that your organization
doesn't have hidden structures
like leadership, policy and culture,
that are in opposition to the mission
of diversity, equity and inclusion.
- I love that, I really
feel compelled by this idea
of sort of a comprehensive approach
to providing pathways, if you will,
for people to have support
and community in these spaces,
at not just the student level,
but also at the faculty level.
The idea of cluster hires,
I think is really important
especially in the STEM fields,
but you talked a little bit
about mentors in your life
who sort of helped you
get to where you are.
You talked about your parents.
I wanna dig a little bit deeper
and find out more about how
those mentorships have shaped,
who you are now
and how you pay that forward in your life
and in your work.
- Yeah, I believe that mentoring
is the single most
important thing that we do.
I think it's a
responsibility for all of us,
and I've been blessed
to have many mentors.
And a lot of times I have many mentors
at the same time working,
serving different roles for me.
So my parents were my first mentors
and they're still my mentors today.
And from them, they
instilled values within me
to value people over money,
to be kind, to love the environment.
I had a wonderful mentor in college,
Professor Osama (indistinct)
and he introduced me to research
and he'd nurtured my curiosity.
And he mentioned me until he passed away,
even through graduate school,
he was a touch point
encouraging me and directing me
cause he had been through that experience.
So he knew what that journey was like.
And then Professor Michael Loewenberg
was a great mentor for me in grad school.
He was tremendously supportive,
encouraging, present,
and a great listener.
And then at NASA, I also
have wonderful mentors
and it's been great
because they knew me
when I was in college.
So they've been with me
for like 10 years now.
And they are great mentors
because they first asked what my goals are
and what I would like to be,
even if that journey isn't at NASA.
Really what do I aspire to do?
And then they're supplying
me with the tools
and guidance to help me
get from point A to B.
So how I pay it forward,
is I perform outreach across K-12 levels
to encourage students to pursue STEM
and to show them what a
scientist can look like,
what science is like
so that they might see themselves in me
and see themselves in the lab.
I have high schoolers through post-docs
that conduct research with me at NASA.
And we're all learning
and growing together,
gaining new skills and
advancing our careers.
And I think it's really easy
that for us to oversimplify
or not realize the gravity
that just one touch or one interaction
can have on a student as they
move through their education.
And at one time in Yale,
I gave a lab tour to some high schoolers
and one of those high schoolers
reached out to me on LinkedIn.
And I'd say every like year and
a half, she sends a message.
Lyndsey, you might not remember me,
but you toured me around your lab
and I'm going to grad school,
and I'm in my third year,
and I'm doing this.
And I'm like, wow.
So it's so valuable.
And there are people who,
it's like two trains passing in the night,
but you make an imprint on them
and you send them in a positive direction.
I think we can all draw from that,
like how Tarek and I were talking about.
The hot and the cold.
So when things aren't going so well,
you draw from those positive interactions
and that encouragement,
and that can really help you get through
to the next sunny spot.
- I think it's so wonderful.
The work that you do to
inspire high school students
and it's a perfect segue into,
and other students as well,
but it's a perfect segue
into one of the questions
that we received from one
of the attendees tonight.
I'd like to jump to it.
It's very specific,
but this person is asking,
what simplified math project
could be used to inspire
their middle school
and high school students
to explore solar energy?
- Oh, that's a good question, that's fun.
So a couple of things come to mind.
So since you're doing math,
I think you can look at solar
from a lot of different vantage points.
You can look at the
economics of solar, right?
How much does a panel cost?
How long is it going to take before,
maybe you're net positive
on this investment?
Maybe you want to compare solar power
over the lifetime of an
operating panel cradle to grave,
to getting equivalent energy
from a coal power plant.
So you can see what is
the environmental impact?
What is the carbon footprint?
What's the best route that you could take?
I think you could look at things
about the structure of your solar panels,
how many panels will you
need to power a certain load
and how much is it gonna weigh?
How big is it going to be?
How much areas it gonna take up?
I think that would be really fun.
So I can think of a few things,
I also like to think of the
human aspect and things.
So aside from cost and weight,
you may be able to think
of developing nations
or the impact of the climate on animals.
And maybe there's some investigations
that they could look
at there too for solar.
- Thank you for that.
That's really helpful.
And Tarek you can jump in at anytime.
We're getting questions
from the attendees tonight.
So I want to kind of get to
those before our time runs out,
but someone in the Q&A asked,
what was your most challenging moment
or experience as a minority female student
in the sciences at Yale?
Or how did you meet or
overcome that challenge?
- Yeah, I had a few challenging moments
but they all had a common thread
and the common thread in
these challenging moments
was people in positions
of authority or power,
or even sometimes my peers,
were committing micro or
macro aggressions against me
to make me feel like I don't belong.
So that could look like someone coming
into a lab that I'm in,
even though you clearly have to be badged
and trained to have access
to a piece of equipment
and asking, "Are you a high-schooler,
what are you doing here?
How did you get here?"
The person who asked me that
was the same person who
trained me on the equipment
that I was a user for.
And that made me feel
really bad in that day.
And it was also one of those days,
Tarek, back to the highs and lows
that nothing in my
experiment was going right
and I didn't want to be there
and I just wanted to be in bed.
And it took everything to drag myself up
and hear gums that like straw
that breaks the camel's back for the day.
So I got through those times
by leaning on my support network.
And that was my now husband Charles Brown,
who then was a very friendly classmate
that provided a lot of support.
And some of my other friends
that I'm still really close to today,
and that was my parents.
And those were my college professor,
and you reach out and tell them,
"This happened today
and this is how I'm feeling."
And they dust you off
and they pick you up,
and maybe they give you some chocolate,
whatever it takes to recharge you
and get you back going.
So it's okay to feel those things
and acknowledge them and take a pause.
But I always reminded myself
that no individual is
going to knock me off
of my life's path.
I didn't want to get taken
out like that, so to speak.
And I refused to let someone win,
cause it's clear that you must
not want me in this space,
but I want to be here.
So I'm going to fight to stay here.
And I also began really
studying the humanities more
and I read a lot of scholarship
about marginalized people
because when you start to see
what the system looks like
and that this is a large system,
and that it might sound
like an offhand comment
someone made to in math class,
but really they're just
reinforcing these gender and race
and societal things
that have been going on
for hundreds of years.
That knowledge in scholarship
has made me a lot more equipped
to identify and handle those
aggressions when I face them.
- Thank you so much Lyndsey.
You were talking a lot about your network
and how important that support system was.
We have a question from
one of our attendees
who is actually, this
person is actually editing
a collection of African-Americans
experiences at Yale.
And is curious about your awareness
or your association
with the Afro American
Cultural Center at Yale.
- Yes, I was very much aware of
and affiliated with the house.
I found community and
support in the house.
I appreciated their programming
and I had a lot of good times there.
I also hosted some events in the house
through the Yale League of Black Scientist
and I was a member of the
Bouschet Honor Society
and still I am.
So that was a very helpful tool for me.
That was where I met
some of my first friends,
at the welcome barbecue.
Very quickly you get the books,
the mountain of textbooks
kind of hits you in the face
and you get locked in the lab.
And for me that was Mason lab,
but I absolutely found
a lot of great community
through the house.
- Thank you for answering.
Another question here.
What is the culture
like regarding diversity
and inclusion at NASA?
- Yeah, so that's a great question.
And the culture is pretty good.
The government has actually
one of the leaders in diversity
and we are typically,
historically, the government
has been a great place
for minoritized people
to find success and employment,
and have upward mobility.
I think it's great that that's the case.
I think it government would fail
if it's federal employees
were not an accurate representation
of the constituents that it represents.
So NASA is good with that.
NASA also has affinity
groups and support networks,
and they facilitate these relationships
and we host listening sessions.
And there is a lot of opportunity
to be your authentic self
and to engage with other
people that are like you.
But also I feel very respected
and included by all members,
all of my colleagues,
which is tremendously important.
And one of the other ways
that I think is more subtle
but it's tremendously impactful,
is how much NASA values
and conducts outreach.
And that is critical to the NASA mission.
We do a lot of things for K through 12.
We do a lot of things
to bring underrepresented
students into science,
get them excited about space
and expose them to them.
And I think that says a
lot about an organization
or agency's values
when they are doing the
work to fill that pipeline,
to release some of those valves
and to get everyone through.
And NASA does that really
well across the board.
- That's great.
It sounds like NASA has
been a really great place
for you to work and to serve also.
We do have a question here,
someone wants to know if
you've ever felt unqualified
for the job or position you were in.
So kind of hitting on imposter syndrome,
how you were able to overcome self doubt,
if you had any?
- Oh, I've had self doubt for sure.
And that's a tough one.
And I think to deal with self doubt,
I remember everything
that I've come through
to get to this point.
I've undergone a lot of training.
I've been through a lot of school,
I've faced a lot of challenges
and I'm still standing, I'm still here.
I find a way to get through all of it.
And you didn't get through all
of these gates by accident.
Nobody accidentally lay you in the college
and you didn't accidentally graduate,
and you accidentally get to grad school,
and you accidentally get a job,
like who has that kind of luck, right?
So at a certain point,
you really need to start to believe
that you're not here by a clerical error,
you earned your spot
and then recall all the things
that previously seemed impossible
that you managed to do
and start to own who you are.
I still have self-doubt,
I still get nerves
or you see this daunting
task in front of you.
And also for that,
my family and my peers that I
went through grad school with,
we hype each other up
and we're not hyping
each other up with lies.
I feel like it's so much easier
for someone external to you
to see your greatness.
So if my friend calls me from grad school
and I was like, "Oh, I don't know how
I'm going to do this."
I'm like, "Girl, are you kidding me?
Do you remember that you did this
and this and this,
and he didn't even help you
and you did this and this."
So it's so easy to see the
greatness in someone else.
So let your friends and
your support network
and your family show a mirror,
hold a mirror up to you
and show you your
greatness and hype you up
because you've done a lot
and you will do so much more.
- Thank you for that.
I know that answer probably
helped a lot of people
who struggled with imposter syndrome.
So thank you.
There's another question here
from one of the attendees
and I am not a scientist,
so I'm just gonna read it
and let you answer as you will,
but the question is,
what is your opinion on
single Adam catalyst?
Do you think that it's possible
to replace nanoparticle
catalyst in the future?
- So I'm actually not
an expert in catalyst,
so I don't have that much to say about it
but I will say in general,
I am a fan of all technology
and all novel methods to solve problems.
One of my least favorite
things about science,
is that people have these
large sweeping opinions
about what is worthwhile to investigate
and what is trivial and
what isn't that exciting.
And I think that that
is a show of arrogance
and oftentimes ignorance.
I find merit in any discovery.
Gratefully when I was trained up at NASA,
one thing they taught me was
a null result is a result.
We write it up and we file it
because if you can tell someone
that this route is a dead end,
that is knowledge that
we as a species need,
we don't need to keep
reinventing the wheel.
So I am a fan of exploring
all avenues of science
and I really wish that funding agencies
and people who make those policy
and decision makers also felt
that everything is worthwhile.
So single catalysts, go for it.
- Thank you.
Tarek, were you gonna unmute?
I thought maybe you had a question.
- Yeah, yeah, I was about to,
no, thank you, this is great.
I keep having this recurring theme
of how Lyndsey understands a lot of times
that a lot of people
will try to put science
in terms of how it impacts society.
And that's good.
And we look at translation,
we look at a lot of things like that,
but the one thing that Lyndsey
reminds us a lot of times,
is that you have to think about
how society impacts your science
and whether it is at the technology level
through holistic approaches,
or it is at the human level.
And talking about an active effort
to figure out how to engage with everyone
and make sure that everyone's got a chance
to learn about science.
It is an active effort
and this is something you
have to do with intent.
And it's great to hear
all about the stories
you've done in and out NASA.
The one thing, as you know
I spent a few years in DC
supporting the federal government
and in nanoscience and
in emerging technologies,
and I just have a true appreciation
for the fact also
that you probably coordinate all across
with other agencies,
not just at NASA, right?
Trying to make sure you consider efforts
and do all that.
And one of the questions we got,
was what are the advantage
of working as a PI at NASA
rather than a private company?
I think there's a lot
and I let you answer it,
but there's this global aspect,
you you're working in an agency
that's looking at the stars at earth.
I mean, it's so large and so big,
but I'll let you answer it.
- Yeah, thank you.
That's a really good question.
So I think there are so many benefits
and I'll share with you
guys some of my favorites.
So one of my favorite things about NASA,
is that we don't do research for profit
and a lot of private places
at the base of research and development,
they're looking at what
will the output of this be?
What can we sell?
How will we make money?
And it's very rare to find opportunities
where you can conduct research
that doesn't have to immediately show
how it's going to make money.
So what that results in,
is that the NASA funds
it's scientists like me
to do research that is
seen in the private sector
as too high risk,
because they don't know
if it will pan out,
they don't quite see the
vision 20, 30 years out.
So I am best at the cutting edge
and we get to be tremendously imaginative
and we get to think of things like
what if we printed
solar cells on the moon?
And it's so fun.
So I really love that opportunity
that I think is unique to
being at a government agency
or specifically at NASA.
Something else, NASA is
working on space travel,
and I find that tremendously exciting.
And the way that we conduct
research at NASA is at first,
there is something
called a decadal survey.
So every 10 years, people sit down
and they think 10 years out.
And the discussion is, where, what space,
what science missions.
So like what planets
or bodies would they like
to visit in 10 years?
And they'll say, "Oh,
it would be really cool
if we could go to (indistinct)
or let's try to set up camp on the moon."
And then from that we divorced,
what technology do we need to invent,
so that we can fulfill this mission.
And that's where the scientists like me,
the engineers come in,
is to create this technology
such that we can conduct those missions.
So we're kind of on demand,
enabling this technology.
And then there are so
many spinoff technologies
that we get from that.
As we develop these things for space,
we find a lot of practical
uses for them here on earth,
and then we spin them out again
to companies that end
up boosting the economy
and giving us this great new technology
that probably would not
have been discovered
if we didn't have that latitude
and that freedom of imagination
to think so wonky and
so far out of the box
and to be so creative.
And I also love that NASA
really values people,
the environment and the communities.
So it it's tremendously
important to me as a person
that I am doing little
to no harm to our earth.
And I appreciate working at a place
that's not polluting,
not robbing resources
and not being a negative
presence on our planet.
So I really appreciate just
the values of our agency.
- This is great.
What I've been hearing also,
I think that resonates
actually in other disciplines,
I feel like, it goes back to that question
about the (indistinct).
I mean, a lot of times you
want to think about the problem
and then think about
the challenge in general
and think about what makes sense,
just like what you do in
biotechnology for example,
what does the biology tell you
and then figure out what makes sense
in terms of what
technologies you want develop
to treat this disease?
And I think, you don't try to
push a particular platform.
It's just for the sake
of it being cool, right?
And so I love that, I'm
also hearing the fact that,
your passion for the environment
and thinking about policy and everything,
I mean, I can imagine for example,
that taking a step back,
you're probably engaging,
for example, EPA or other.
Did you ever have an instance
when you were like you're
actually affecting policy
at a higher level?
- Yeah, so I think that's
something also I appreciate
about being with the government,
is we are the eyes and ears
and the checkpoints of the government.
So we're the subject matter experts
that our leaders are,
congressional leaders and our lawmakers
and our policymakers rely
on to say, "Is this good?
Should we be doing this?
Maybe we should not be doing this,
should we fund this more?
Is this what direction
should we be going in?"
So I appreciate being in that position.
And although I can say those are wings
that I'm still growing
and I haven't entirely
taken off on that yet,
that's something that I'm really excited
and passionate about
because I think these
decisions need to be made
thinking about the long-term
longevity of our species.
We need to be thinking about everyone,
any technology, any large
decisions or directions we take,
need to benefit all people.
So these are some of the things
that I'm really interested in,
and there are opportunities
for that cross-pollination.
NASA is sometimes seen
as the wonkier folks
when we do sit down cause
we're with the air force, army,
and the Navy
and they have their
viewpoint of the world.
And we're literally over here,
like, let's just hold hands,
wouldn't it be cool if,
so we're a bit of the
flower child in that way,
but I think we're really
valuable in that sense.
- That's great, thank you.
We actually have a really,
really fun question to hear
from the Colorado Yale Association.
Have you watched the new "Dune" movie
and you like science
fiction or Afro futurism?
I love that movie by the way.
- And I watch which movie?
- [Tarek] The New Dune.
- Yes, I did watch that.
And that was fun.
I've really been getting
into sci-fi lately.
I've been reading it a bit
more than watching movies
cause that's a bit more my speed,
but yeah, I enjoyed that movie
and I also love sci-fi
and I get really excited by sci-fi,
they provide a lot of like
information and perspectives
and kind of situations that
I hadn't considered yet.
And then I'm like, "Could this happen,
is this real?"
Like maybe, so then I'm amped up
and I want to go into the lab
and try to make it happen.
So, yeah, I'm a big fan.
- That's really cool.
Yeah, I'm a big fan of the movie.
I really just, I was on
my seat the whole time
and that was just wild.
It was great.
All right, well, I don't know Danica,
do you think we have room,
maybe like one last question?
- Yeah, I think maybe
for one last question,
Lyndsey, thank you for that answer.
I must admit, I do not know
that popular cultural reference,
so I'm going to have
to catch up on "Dune."
Sounds like something I should be into,
but just for one you
closing question here,
it's a big one,
but I'm hoping that you'll
have a succinct answer.
What is the one piece of advice
you would give to Yale
students in the audience?
- Oh, that's a great one.
I'm going to cheat
and give one personal advice
and one professional advice.
So the personal advice I
would tell Yale students is,
remember that life goes on
while you're in grad school.
So this is like four to
seven plus 10 ish years
that you're there,
but time isn't going to stand still.
So nurture relationships with
your family and your friends,
and be sure you take time for them
because they're aging,
they're moving, they're
going through life.
And those milestones that
we experience as people
are tremendously valuable.
Professionally, I would say listen.
Listen to things that you don't think
are necessarily relevant
to your field of study
or your goals, or your
career, or your life.
There's just so much to learn
from every discipline
and the world we live in is
tremendously interdisciplinary.
So I pull from various fields
in science in my research
and humanities scholarship continues
to provide me with a roadmap
to life as I navigate through.
So be sure you listen a lot
and have fun and learn something new.
- Thank you so much Lyndsey.
I think I can speak for everyone and say,
this has been delightful.
Everything you've said today,
I think has been so impactful
and I'm taking personally away
a lot from this conversation.
So we just appreciate
you giving of your time
and being so generous with your research
and your sort of mentorship
and outreach initiatives,
and sort of helping us
to really understand how
to create spaces for us
and for students to create spaces,
especially that are nurturing
and will help them thrive
while here at Yale.
I also want to thank Lynn Cooley.
I wanna thank Tarek
for being such a great
co-moderator with me
and thank you all for
the questions submitted.
It made for a very lively
and important conversation.
To all the students and
alumni who tuned in tonight,
I hope you've enjoyed the discussion
and will continue to help us
build a stronger community
among graduate students,
faculty, and alumni at Yale.
I'd also like to invite you
to the graduate schools,
graduate student reach
across disciplines webinar,
which will happen on December 8th.
And I believe we're going to drop the link
for the registration for
that webinar in the chat
if you'd like to sign up.
Before we sign off tonight,
I'd like to remind anyone
who has not already done so,
to join Cross Campus,
Yale's online networking,
community building and
mentoring program across campus,
is a fantastic way for alumni and students
to connect with one another.
And if there are other ways
in which you'd like to be more involved
in supporting the graduate school,
please reach out to us.
Send us an email at GSAS@Yale.edu.
We look forward to hearing from you soon
and to gathering with you again.
Thank you all for being here this evening.